according to a study from Child Trends
just nine percent of children lived with
single parents in the 1960s before the
rise of modern feminism by 2012 that
number had increased to nearly 30
percent in 2019 Pugh found that the
United States has the highest rate of
children living in single-family homes
of any country in the world divorce is a
major driving factor for these numbers
of course from the 1960s to 1980s
divorce rates in the U.S more than
doubled you'll often see studies showing
that in the last few years divorce rates
are down but that's only because many
people aren't bothering to get married
in the first place they've just given up
on the whole Institution